breaking news out of Pakistan at this
hour where the Supreme Court has
declared the arrests of former prime
minister Imran Khan illegal and ordered
his release security was tied ahead of
his appearance after two days of
Nationwide protests over his arrest
Imran Khan appeared in another court on
Wednesday and was remanded in custody
for eight days he faces multiple charges
including corruption these are live
pictures from outside the court in
Islamabad where Osama bin Javid is for
his Osama
there's been a bit of action in the last
few minutes outside of the Court there
tell us about what's been happening
Osama bin Javid uh can you hear me
okay we we are having connection issues
with our correspondent Osama bin Javit
but that's a live picture
outside of the court in Pakistan
Islamabad Pakistan whether High Court uh
just uh
moments ago
declared the arrest of former prime
minister Imran Khan illegal and ordered
his release
there seems to have been some clashes
between Imran Khan's supporters and
security forces outside of the Court
there in Islamabad these are the latest
pictures that are coming into us we'll
update you on the situation once we
establish connection with our
correspondent Osama bin Javid who's
outside the court